ERIK KUEFLER: Hi, everyone.
My name is Erik Kuefler.
I'm going to be talking
today about MVP and
the EventBus in GWT.
Let's get started.
So going into this talk, I'm
going to assume that you're
all GWT developers.
You all have some experience
developing GWT.
And in particular, you've
worked with UI Binder to
define your static layouts, and
you're familiar with the
basics of GIN for using
dependency injection.
I'll rely on both of those
a bit during my slides.
So if you've done much reading
into best practices in GWT, at
some point, you've probably come
across Ray Ryan's 2009
Tech Talk titled "Best Practices
for Architecting
your GWT Applications." Who
here has seen that?
So quite a few people.
In some sense, this Tech Talk
follows onto that and talks
about some of the
same concepts.
So if you've seen it, that's
some good background.
But if not, I'll reintroduce the
same things here, so you
shouldn't miss anything.
So here are some questions I'm
going to answer with this
presentation.
I'm going to talk basically
about what MVP is, why it's
useful, and some strategies
for implementing it.
And importantly, I'm going to
also talk about when you
should avoid MVP and stick with
something simpler instead.
Once I go through that, I'm
going to talk about combining
a lot of these components
together and getting them
communicating in a maintainable
way using the EventBus.
As for who I am, I'm currently
a software
engineer on Google Wallet.
I've been working with GWT
applications for about the
past four years across five or
six large GWT applications.
So I've had a little bit of a
chance to see how my own bad
architectural decisions can
pile up and some chance to
figure out how to
do things right.
But I'm not affiliated with
the GWT team, I'm just
presenting it here.
So before we start, I want
to define what our goals
in doing this are.
In defining the architecture for
our application, we really
have two things we're trying
to accomplish.
The first is testability, which
is a very broad topic.
And here, I'm going to use
a pretty restrictive
definition for it.
I'm going to say that your GWT
application is testable if
almost the entirety of the
business logic that's specific
to your application can be
tested using plain Java JVM
test cases.
The alternative to this, as
you're probably aware, is to
use GWT test case.
And those are a lot more
heavyweight and more complex.
They actually compile your
application down to JavaScript
and run them in a
fake browser.
So this is great when you're
testing actual UI flows and
things like widgets.
But when you're just testing
pure business logic, it's
overkill, because those
tests run an order
of magnitude slower.
And you don't have
nice tools like
mocking frameworks available.
So as much as possible, we want
to make the interesting
parts of our application
testable just
as normal Java code.
Our second objective here,
equally as important, is
maintainability.
And this is also, of course,
a very broad topic.
Here, I'm going to define
maintainability with a simple
definition saying that your
application is maintainable if
making simple changes to it is
really easy and making more
complex changes is possible.
So in contrast, in an
unmaintainable application, I
might describe to you something
really simple using
just a few lines of English.
And it might take you 100
lines of code across 10
different files to
implement that.
If that's your case, you've
probably got a
maintainability problem.
So we want to make our
application testable while
still keeping it easy
to work with.
How do we accomplish this?
The standard pattern that's
common in the GWT community is
MVP, Model-View-Presenter.
Let's define what
exactly that is.
MVP is a really straightforward
pattern.
It just involves breaking your
application up into three
separate components--
the Model, the View,
and the Presenter.
So at the bottom, you have your
model, which contains all
the state of your application,
everything it actually knows
about the user.
And then at the top, you have
the View, which is responsible
for actually displaying that
state, converting it into DOM
browser widgets, and presenting
it to the user.
And then in the middle, you
have probably the most
interesting component, which
is the Presenter, which is
responsible for all the
interesting business logic of
your application, everything
that is actually tricky and
the kinds of stuff
we want to test.
And the motivation for breaking
things up like this
in MVP when we're using GWT is
that the View tends to contain
a lot of code that we don't
really want to deal with as
much that's a lot
harder to test.
That's for stuff where you have
to work with the DOM, you
have to run JavaScript, you
have to deal with widgets.
So if you factor this out into
its own class separate from
your Presenter, that means that
in your tests, you can
take out this View, replace it
with a super fast mock View,
and then you can write
pure Java test just
against your Presenter.
And that all works
pretty well.
That's pretty much all there is
to the MVP pattern itself.
So let's talk a little bit
about how you actually go
about implementing this.
So first of all, it turns out
that the model here isn't all
that interesting.
Usually, the model is just a
fairly straightforward Java
value object that maybe have
some observers on it.
In some simple stateless
applications, you don't need a
model at all.
So I'm not going to talk
too much about it.
I'm really going to focus on
describing how to implement
the View and the Presenter
and how those work.
And the key question when you're
talking about this is
really, how much of my code goes
in the View, and how much
goes into the Presenter?
Do I keep a lot of interesting
logic in the View, or do I try
to keep it as lightweight
as possible?
And you can fall in different
places along this spectrum.
Let's talk about each of them
real quickly before I go into
some heavier code samples.
So your first option is to
define a fairly rich View that
has a lot of code inside it.
So if you're following this
definition, you might think of
the View as a component that
contains all of my
application's display logic.
If you're following this
philosophy, you probably end
up with methods in your View
that looks something like what
you have over here
on the right.
You have a big monolithic
method in your View.
It takes a contact object.
So here we're creating some
sort of address book.
It goes through, it
takes out contact.
It does the work of converting
it into labels and sticking
them into the UI somehow.
And this is nice.
The advantage here is, as we
described for MVP, you've
separated all this DOM code
out into your View.
You don't need to deal with
it from your Presenter.
It's encapsulated
for your tests.
But there are some downsides
to doing it this way.
The first big downside is that
I described here the View as
being a component that
encapsulates all of your
display logic.
But I haven't really described
what display logic is.
And that's because it's
pretty vague.
The kind of things we're doing
here-- concatenating names
together, iterating over
phone numbers--
it's related to what we display
to the user, but
there's also interesting
business logic there
we'd like to test.
Whether it goes into the View or
the Presenter ends up being
a coin flip.
The other problem here is that
if you think back two slides
when we were talking about our
MVP and testing it, we said
that when we started testing
MVP, when we start testing our
Presenter, we're going to
throw out this View and
replace it with a mock
implementation, which means
that all this code we have here
isn't really going to be
covered by our fast tests.
Either we'll write heavyweight
GWT test cases for them, or we
won't bother testing
them at all.
Put those two facts together,
and I found that when I used
to write Views like this, I
would find that I would end up
defining display logic
as the logic that
I'm too lazy to test.
So if I didn't feel like testing
something someday, I'd
throw it in the View and say,
oh, it's in the View.
I don't have to test it.
How convenient.
And that's obviously not
a great place to be.
So we want to try to simplify
this a little.
Last point I want to touch on
this slide here is that it's
not making very good
use of UI binder.
When MVP was first introduced,
UI binder wasn't available,
and we had to build our
interfaces like this in this
very swing-like, imperative way
where we create labels and
add them to a bunch
of containers.
These days, UI binder let's us
do this a lot more simply.
What we have here is basically
a static layout, and we can
basically do this in XML.
So our definition for a View
should really take advantage
of that technology.
So let's try simplifying
this a little.
So let's say rather than
containing this notion of some
sort of display logic, let's say
that the View is just this
very thin wrapper around widgets
in a ui.xml file.
If you're following this
approach, you probably end up
with a View that looks
something like this.
Rather than having a single
monolithic method, you end up
with a bunch of small methods
that are just basically
pass-throughs to one-liner
widget calls.
So to set the name, I take a
string, and I pass it as the
text to the name field--
really straightforward.
This has all the advantages of
the richer View that has a lot
of display logic in that it
keeps the DOM out of your
Presenter so you can
still test it.
But also, all that code we had
before gets moved out to your
Presenter, which means it stays
in the realm of nice,
clean unit test.
So this ends up being a lot more
testable, defining your
Views in a simple way like this
that have as little logic
as possible.
The big disadvantage here is
that this can be very tedious
to maintain.
So all that code I had on the
previous slide didn't go away.
It was moved to the Presenter.
And in its place, I have these
uninteresting one-line methods.
In this example, it's
not too bad.
I only have three widgets and
three methods plus a callback.
But you can imagine that in an
interesting View, I might end
up with dozens and dozens of
widgets, each of which would
have to expose a couple of these
methods, and I wind up
with hundreds of lines of code
that is just pure boilerplate,
uninteresting, and a
pain to maintain.
So in this case, the
View really isn't
providing much value.
And what I suggest doing if you
have a rather static View
like this, is just getting rid
of the View entirely, not
relying on MVP in this case, and
just building much simpler
single composites, kind of like
you might have if you'd
never heard about MVP
in the first place.
There's a lot of advantages
to doing this.
And I'll run through some more
code samples, what all three
of these strategies look
like in just a moment.
So obviously, there's a huge
advantage in that I just
deleted a whole slide worth of
code, and things work more or
less the same.
There's less boilerplate.
There's less to write.
And the fact that you have less
code there means there's
nowhere for your code
to hide from tests.
If you only have one single
class, there's no ambiguity
about what logic goes
in the View and
what goes in the Presenter.
It's logic, so it has to go in
the Java file, which means
that you have no excuse
not to test it fully.
So for very static Views,
this can be a big
improvement over using MVP.
The obvious disadvantage here is
that by getting rid of this
View, you have lost a layer
of encapsulation.
If you do have a lot of
interesting DOM logic, if
you're doing a lot of
interesting manipulation, it
might be valuable to keep that
View around and stick with it.
But let's run through some
examples of what all three of
these strategies look like.
So first, here's how some code
might look if you're writing
something using the rich
View strategy.
So over on the left, you
have your Presenter.
In the middle, you
have a View.
And on the right, you
have a UI XML file.
Here, the interesting
part's highlighted.
So you see here that actually
most of the interesting logic
here in this example ends up
falling into the View in the
middle here.
And from a maintainability
standpoint, this is fine.
There's not much duplication.
I pretty much only have
to write things once.
But the real problem here is
testability, because you can
imagine that in our fast Java
unit tests, we're going to
eliminate this View in the
middle here and just test the
things over on the left
on the Presenter.
There's really not much
interesting there to test.
So we're not getting much
testable value there.
So we can improve testability by
basically taking that chunk
in the View and pushing it out
to the Presenter, where it's
covered by our tests.
Once we've done that, we've
moved to our much simpler View
strategy, where the interesting
code is moved over
to the Presenter, and in its
place in the View are these
very simple one-liner methods
that I talked about.
So our interface from the
Presenter into the View,
rather than having a single
monolithic method, has these,
in this case, two methods to do
some low-level operations
into the View.
And testability-wise,
this is great.
The stuff that's left in the
View is really boring.
Even I'd be OK if you didn't
write tests for that.
All the stuff that's
worth caring about
is over in the Presenter.
The real problem here, again,
is maintainability.
So imagine what you'd have to do
to add a new field to this
component here.
You'd first have to go
into your ui.xml
file and define it.
You'd then have to define
it again as a UI
field in your View.
And then based on all properties
you wanted to
access to that-- maybe it's
text, maybe it's visibility--
you'd have to add an extra
method in your View for each
of those things you
wanted to change.
Then in your Presenter in the
display interface up here, you
would have to define those
methods again.
And then only after you've done
that could you actually
start writing the business
logic that you wanted to.
So that's a lot of work to just
do something as simple as
defining a field.
So it would be great if we could
just get rid of these
methods here that are pure
boilerplate and aren't telling
us anything valuable.
Once we've done that, we move
to this simple non-MVP
composite strategy.
And you see how this
looks here is we
have a single composite.
It contains a bunch of UI
fields, like a View.
But otherwise, it looks
like a Presenter.
The logic here is basically
the same, only rather than
making a call against a wrapping
View class, we're
making a call to a
widgets directly.
And this is a big improvement
maintainability-wise.
Now if I want to define a new
field, all I have to do is
define the UI XML file,
define a UI field, and
then start using it.
There's a lot fewer steps.
And the testability here
is also great, too.
And I'll talk about exactly how
you can test this soon.
But the idea is you have
one single class.
You can cover this
entire thing with
your Java test cases.
So your entire logic
is testable easily.
And you might say, but wait,
the whole point of the View
was to get these widgets out
of the Presenter, put them
somewhere else so I don't
have to deal with
them and their tests.
And that's true, but it turns
out that testing widgets
directly from Java Test isn't
that hard anymore.
It used to be the case that it
was a lot harder to do this,
but there are tools in place
now that can help you.
And so the key insight here is
that if I define this View in
order to mock it out for my
tests, why can't I just define
mocks for these widgets and
mock them out directly?
And you can do that now.
Basically, all you have to do to
make this work is, in your
set up method, you call this
one disarm method on
GWTMockUtilities.
That'll make sure that when
you call [? GWT.create ?]
in your Java unit tests, rather
than things blowing up,
it'll just harmlessly
return a null.
And then when you actually
instantiate your widget,
there's just this one method
you have to override with a
NOOP implementation, since
otherwise, it would run
JavaScript for you, which
would break things.
So once you've done those two
things, you have your widget
constructed.
And it's basically just going to
have nulls in all of its UI
fields there.
And since those UI fields are
package private, you can go
through in your tests and assign
fake implementations to
all of them.
So here, I'm just pushing
Mockito mocks in each of my
fields here.
You can use your own EasyMock
mocks, roll your own mocks--
whatever you want.
And once I've done that, my
tests become really easy.
So this test looks a lot like
what I'd be writing
if I was using MVP.
If I'm testing the set contact
method on this contact object,
all I do is pass it in
my contact objects--
first name, Fred, last
name, Smith--
and then verify that that name
widget was set to the text
Fred Smith.
So this is exactly the same
verification I'd make against
the View, only now I'm making
it against that widget
directly, which improves my test
coverage, since there's
nothing in between.
This is a little bit of work
to set this all up.
If you want to, today I'm open
sourcing a library called GWT
Mockito that we're using
internally on a few Google
teams that helps you clean
this up a little.
If you're using this, all you
have to do is annotate your
test with this GWT Mockito
test runner.
It'll take care of automatically
doing all this
disarming for you.
It'll automatically populate all
your UI field with mocks,
which means that in your tests,
all you have to do is
instantiate your object and
write your test directly.
So there's a link here.
You can check that out if
it looks useful to you.
But if you undo this out of the
box in GWT, it's not too
bad, and it improves your
maintainability and
testability.
And so that's basically it.
So that describes how
you can test these
fairly static Views.
And I've really been advocating
for this approach
of when you have a simple static
View, rather than going
full MVP, you should just do
it much more simply with a
single composite object.
And of course, there are
some downsides to that.
So the big obvious thing, as I
said, that we're missing here
is that we no longer have this
extra layer encapsulating
display logic.
And if you're writing something
really complex, like
say, a game in HTML5 or
something that does a lot of
very interesting DOM
manipulation,
that will hurt you.
And you probably do want
to keep [? this View ?]
around to factor
that stuff out.
But in most of the applications
I've worked with,
and probably most applications
you guys work with, what we
have is a fairly static View.
Maybe we add or remove a few
elements, but we've basically
just got a form that we're
sticking values into and
pulling values back out of.
And in that case, there's really
no extra value gained
by adding the separate
View layer.
Another thing we partially give
up is the ability to swap
out different implementations
of Views for the single
display interface.
We still have that a little,
since we can define different
UI XML files, which let us
move the layout around.
But we no longer have the
ability to use completely
separate implementations
of our Views.
I've found that in practice,
this isn't something comes up
very often.
Most of the time, you know
what your View is
going to look like.
You have a single implementation
of it.
So you just do that.
But those few times where
you do want multiple
implementations of your Views,
it can, again, make sense to
fall back to the more
complex strategy.
The general rule of thumb here,
though, is that you
should always start with the
simplest thing that works.
It's never very hard to go back
and factor out an extra
interface or an extra
class if you
decide that it's necessary.
There's not much cost to doing
that, over doing it in the
first place.
But by avoiding it until you
need it, you save yourself a
whole lot of work
in the meantime.
That's how I generally tend
to approach these things.
So that's about it for MVP and
how you implement the MVP
pattern and its alternatives
and when
you should and shouldn't.
The real interesting question
comes in, though, when you
start getting multiples of these
components together and
having each of them talk to each
other, because I'm sure
you've all experienced code
where you have no discipline
in what talks to what.
You wind up with a big nest
of spaghetti code where
everything is completely
dependent on everything, and
you can't make changes without
breaking your entire
application.
So that's what we really
want to avoid here.
So when you first start thinking
about hierarchically
decomposing your application,
the thing you're naturally
going to go to is some sort
of tree structure.
And so if you're implementing a
Gmail-like application over
here, you have some roots, body
element that contains a
big mailbox in the center and
maybe a bar along the top and
the bottom and so on.
Each of those elements contains
their children.
And this works great,
visually.
It's a close mirror to the DOM
and how the DOM works and
having these elements all
contain one another.
And for defining the visual
layout of your application,
this is a really natural
thing to do.
There's not much to say here.
It just works.
The real problem comes in,
though, is when you start
using this structure to also
define the communication
between the different
components in your
application.
So let's give an example
of that.
So let's say you've written
this Gmail application.
It's all good.
You're about to ship it.
And then, at the last moment,
your product manager comes and
says, oh, I need one
tiny new feature.
I need, when you click on one
of the messages, I need to
show a spinner over in the top
bar while we wait for that
message to load.
And you say, sure, no problem.
That sounds easy enough.
But then when you look at this
tree here, you try to decide
how should you do that.
And the fundamental problem here
is that you're trying to
pass a message from one leaf
node in your tree to a leaf
node somewhere way off
on another branch.
Your first thought about how to
do that is, OK, maybe I'll
just inject this buttons bar
over into the message and have
it call a method directly.
That'll work for your immediate
solution, but if you
keep following that approach,
you quickly wind up with
everyone's injected to everyone,
everyone talks to
everyone, and you can't make
a change everywhere without
pulling apart your entire
application.
So you do want to try to
maintain this tree structure
and not just inject everything
everywhere.
So if you're doing that, what
you end up deciding you have
to do is do this traversal of
the tree, where the message
calls into some call back on the
mailbox, the mailbox calls
into some call back on the root,
it calls some method
into the top bar, which then
calls a method down to the
spinner to show it.
And this is really even worse
than just doing the direct
injection, because now this one
line, very simple thing I
told you to implement, requires
you to touch five
different classes, probably
write two dozen lines of
callback code.
And once you're done, you wind
up with these three classes in
the middle here knowing about
this interaction that they
shouldn't actually know
anything about at all.
It doesn't concern them.
If you follow this approach, you
wind up with the root node
here knowing about absolutely
everything that happens in
your application.
And it's just this one big god
class that does everything.
So what we really want to be
able to do is have these
components talk more or less
directly to each other without
actually knowing about one
another, which sounds like a
paradox, but that's what
the EventBus is
going to help resolve.
So what's the EventBus?
The EventBus is a pretty
simple concept.
It's this global static
singleton object that's
injected into each of
your Presenters.
And then rather than the
Presenter sending messages to
each other, they all send
messages to that EventBus, and
the EventBus is then responsible
for dispatching it
out to the Presenters that
are interested in them.
So when you're using this
concept, the goal is to really
decouple the visual hierarchy of
your application from your
communication model.
So visually, you have these UI
components that all visually
contain each other, have their
logic off to the side that
just drives the UI but
doesn't otherwise
know about each other.
But communication-wise, you have
something that looks a
lot more like a star or a wheel,
where at the hub, you
have this EventBus, which is
responsible for passing
messages back and forth.
And then along the spokes, you
have these Presenters, which
take those messages and
percolate them out to the View
as needed, or take clicks
from the View and
fire them as messages.
Point being here, these
Presenters are all on the
spokes completely isolated
from each other.
So they don't know anything
about one another.
And the reason we do this
is maintainability.
When the Presenters don't know
anything about one another, it
makes it very easy to add or
modify or remove code without
touching other code.
So here if I decide I don't need
this guy on the bottom
anymore, I just rip out that
spoke, and everything works
exactly the same.
I don't have to touch any
other code really.
You could imagine that if I
had everything injecting
everything, getting rid of that
component would probably
require a day's work of going
down and deleting
references to it.
But here, it's easy.
There's no the changes
I have to make.
So let's zoom in on the
center here to see
exactly how this works.
Like I said, the EventBus is the
singleton component that
is injected into each
of your Presenters.
When your application starts,
or when the Presenter is
loaded, they go through and tell
the EventBus what events
they are interested in, where
an event is just something
that happens in your
application.
So here, I have a Presenter
for my chat screen, a
Presenter for my Compose window,
and they're each going
to tell the EventBus, OK, I'm
interested in when a contact
gets added, because I need to
add that to my UI somehow.
Then the Presenter is going to
say, OK, I'm also interested
in when the Compose button
gets clicked,
so I can show myself.
They have no idea what's
actually going to fire those
events, but they've told the
EventBus that when they are
fired, let me know.
Then you have a third Presenter
come in, your
contact Presenter here, where
your user actually goes
through and adds
these contacts.
And when the user does that,
it sends a message to the
EventBus saying, OK,
fire this event.
The EventBus looks up who's
interested, and it dispatches
it out to each of those
components and lets them do
what they want with them.
That's pretty straightforward.
How does this actually work?
When people first hear about
this, they tend to think this
is some sort of complex object
that is doing some sort of
asynchronous magical dispatch
of these events, but it's
really very simple.
And I can pretty much implement
an entire EventBus
on a slide here.
So the heart of the EventBus is
really this map from events
to lists of event handlers.
Registering an event handler
just involves adding a new
entry to that list for the
appropriate event.
And firing an event just
involves looking up that list
of handlers, iterating
over it, and calling
each of them in turn.
So that's what you should think
of an event firing as,
as just calling a bunch
of methods in a loop.
It's really straightforward.
GWT, of course, defines a
built-in EventBus that is much
more full featured than this.
It does nice things like
error handling.
But if you use this as your
mental model, it'll get you
through 95% of cases.
How do you actually use it
in your application?
There's basically three steps
you have to follow.
First, you define your events.
Out of the box, this is actually
a little surprisingly
verbose in GWT.
You have to extend GWT event
with a class that overrides
this dispatch and get
type methods.
And then you have to define an
interface as a handler for
that event.
I'm not going to go into details
of that there, but
it's on the slide.
Another library I'm releasing
today that we've been using
internally inside Google is
called EventBinder, which
helps you clean up a lot of
the boilerplates around
dealing with an EventBus.
So if you're using EventBinder,
you're basically
just defining your contact
loaded event here as normal
immutable Java value type.
In a common case where your
event doesn't have any
arguments associated with it,
this just becomes a one line
definition here.
When you have the slightly more
interesting case, when
you're carrying parameters,
you've basically just got a
value object that looks
something like this.
Your next step is to actually
register handlers for those
events to say who's interested
in hearing them.
Again, out of the box in GWT,
there's a little bit of work
you have to do, in you
invoke this EventBus.
You pass in these anonymous
handler instances that either
do work or call out to
methods that do work.
It's not too bad, but if you're
using EventBinder, this
is simplified a bit in that all
you have to do is apply
this Add Event Handler
annotation to
each of your methods.
And this looks a lot
like the UI Handler
annotation in UIBinder.
And in fact, it works in much
the same way, where just by
looking at that first argument
to the method, it decides what
event it needs to listen to.
And then you just need to call
one line to bind those in your
constructor.
So either way, once you've done
that, you're saying that
any time a contact loaded event
is fired anywhere in my
application, invoke this method,
and let me know.
So link there for EventBinder
is up.
You can check that out on
GitHub if you want.
But it's also fine if you bind
these manually, if you want to
get started.
And the final step, fortunately,
is really easy no
matter what you're doing.
You just have to construct
that event and
fire it on the EventBus.
And all you do here is you call
the constructor on the
event you defined earlier
and pass it to
this fire event method.
And then if you think back to
the EventBus implementation we
talked about earlier, what this
means here is that you
are just in a loop calling
over all those individual
event handler methods that
you've defined earlier.
So basically, when you fire
this event, you don't know
what methods you're calling,
but the EventBus will take
care of internally
dispatching that.
That's pretty much all
there is to it.
So with the rest of my time
here, I just want to talk
about a few best practices for
using the EventBus, since if
you're not disciplined about
how you define your events,
you definitely can get into this
fairly complex scenario
where you have a lot of events
going back and forth, and it's
tough to figure out
what's going on.
So how should you think
about events?
Superficially, they can seem
kind of similar to methods, in
that both an event and a method
are a message that
sends from one class to another,
possibly carrying
some number of arguments.
That's about where the
similarity ends.
The big difference between
methods and events is that
when you're dealing with
methods, you have a single
known receiver.
You know exactly who you're
calling, what they're going to
do in response, and you can
expect them to give you some
value back out.
Events are totally different
in that when you fire an
event, you have no idea who's
listening to it, you have no
idea how many people are
listening to it, and maybe no
one's even listening
to it at all.
And as a consequence,
you don't get a
return value back out.
You can't trust anything in
particular to happen in
response to firing an event.
So how these end up being used
is that you keep using methods
for the tightly coupled
components of your application
that really do know a lot
about each other's
implementation details, say,
a Presenter class and some
helper that's directly tied
to that Presenter.
Events, in contrast, are used
for much higher level
notifications when something big
and major happens in your
application that a lot of code
might care about, but you
don't really care from
where it happens,
what happens in response.
And really, the important word
I use there is notification.
You should think of events as
notifications, not commands.
So in a sense, you can think of
event-driven programming as
a more polite and collaborative
form of
programming.
Rather than having a bunch of
individual components that are
all ordering each other what
to do, calling methods,
demanding some particular action
being taken, you have a
bunch of components that
all raise events.
Say this interesting
thing happened.
Maybe you would like to do
something in response to that.
And structuring your application
that way ends up
being a lot more maintainable
and easy to plug into.
You can tell if you're falling
afoul of this rule by looking
at the names of your events.
So say a user clicks
the button to
open the Contact Manager.
I know I have to load the
contacts from the server.
There are two ways I
might model this.
The first would be to fire a
load contact from server
events, named like that.
That's not a great idea, because
it's demanding a
particular action be taken.
It's not very extensible,
because the only way I could
respond to an event with that
name is to load the contacts
from the server.
Instead, I should fire an event
that represents what
actually happens, so
in this case, a
ContactManagerOpened event.
In that case, I can still
have the server
listen for that event.
Say the Contact Manager
was opened, I'd
better load the contacts.
Then I could also have the UI
listen for that event and say
Contact Manager was opened.
I'd better show my pop up.
And then a year later, if I
decide I want to add some sort
of analytics handler, I can
just add a new handler, it
listens to that event, and I
don't have to touch anything
to make that work.
In practice, 99% of the time,
the events in our application
fall into two categories.
Either they are user inputs,
responds to a user click in
some way, or they are responses
coming back from the
server, some asynchronous
call finished.
There's no magical reason
this has to be the case.
It's just the fact that in most
web applications, these
end up being the major things
that happen, and that's what
our events tend to represent.
You can get into some other
instances, like maybe you have
a postMessage response,
and you fire an event
as a result of that.
But those instances are
relatively rare.
That's pretty much it.
Let's run through one final
example of all this code put
together before I move
on to questions.
So here we see a component
that's using everything we
talked about.
It's condensed enough to fit
onto one slide here.
So there's a few interesting
things to note that
are going on here.
The single component has a
fairly static UI, so rather
than using MVP, I'm just
defining this as one single
composite class.
It's a widget.
It extends composite.
It has a bunch of UI
fields inside it.
Here I have a child class, which
is something else I've
defined in my system, called
InfoCard, which is maybe
something that pops up when
I hover over a contact.
In order to implement that, I
am injecting that component
into my composite and then
assigning it to a field
declared as a widget.
The reason I'm assigning it to
a widget field rather than an
InfoCardComposite field is that
I don't want to do any
communication with
this guy directly
once I have it injected.
I want to take it, stick in
my UI, and then basically
forget about it.
Once I've done that, you see
that every other method inside
this composite here
is either an event
handler or a UI handler.
In particular, this thing has
no public methods at all.
So the only way to communicate
with this guy is by either
interacting with it via
the UI or by firing
events on the EventBus.
And that reflects the two
directions in which
my events can flow.
Either we have a user click that
initiates something that
maybe gets propagated out to the
rest of the system, or we
have a server call back, which
will fire an event, and
everyone who cares about
that server call
will respond to it.
The fact that you've broken it
up like this also means that
this thing is very testable.
Basically, your tests
are all just tests
of these event handlers.
So you test says, OK, what
happens when someone clicks
that picture?
I click the picture, I
expect to do this.
What happens when the
contact is loaded?
I fire a contact loaded
event, and I assert
what happens in response.
So maintainable, testable--
those are the goals we're
trying to accomplish.
So to summarize here, when
you're dealing with static UIs
when you have symbol display
logic or none at all, there's
no reason to go full into MVP.
You can greatly reduce
boilerplate, improve your test
coverage with no real loss just
by dealing with single
simple components.
Once you're defined your
individual components, via MVP
or not, you want to use an
EventBus to decouple these and
make it easier to communicate
between things, add
components, and remove
components.
That'll work as long as you
define your events to
represent notifications,
high-level, broad
notifications rather than
individual low-level commands.
And the general philosophy I
want to repeat here again is
that in general, you're best
off starting with a very
simple solution, doing the
simplest thing that can work,
and adding additional complexity
only as needed.
You end up not having to spend
any extra work adding that
complexity later than if you
added it up front, and in the
meanwhile, you get a big benefit
of not having to deal
with that complexity that
you don't need.
I can take some questions now.
Here's a link to both those
libraries that are up here,
and you could also follow me
on GitHub or on Google+.
There are microphones up if
anyone wants to ask questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: GWT does a lot of
optimization when it complies
to JavaScript, like I'm thinking
specifically of
inlining of method calls.
And if you use this EventBus
strategy where you basically
call the methods on some objects
in a list, I would
imagine that that optimization,
for example, the
inlining just goes away.
Is there any way around that,
or how much of that
optimization would we lose?
Is that an impact that
you've seen?
ERIK KUEFLER: Yeah, that's
probably true that you're
definitely introducing an extra
layer here, which is
going to make it a little
harder to optimize.
However, if you're using these
events to represent high-level
things like user clicks or
server responses, those end up
being infrequent enough that
the extra level of a
JavaScript call is completely
irrelevant.
So if you're using an EventBus
to fire off thousands of
events every second, you
would definitely
run into issues there.
But I think if you're doing
that, you're probably doing
something wrong.
So as long as your events are
tied to single, discrete,
external actions, optimization
on that level just isn't
something that's
very important.
AUDIENCE: That makes sense.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So how much of this
code or strategy do we need to
change to make a cross-platform
app?
So let's say you want to create
an Android app, which
can [? take help of ?]
using code from Presenter.
What strategy is here to reuse
as much code as possible?
ERIK KUEFLER: So that falls back
into that case I talked
about earlier, where if you
want to provide multiple
implementations for
this View--
maybe one on GWT,
one on Android--
using that View interface
is valuable.
If you're doing these things
for your Presenters, your
single components reference
the UI field directly, you
obviously can't do that
quite as much.
So I found in practice, it tends
to be really hard to
share the entire UI across
different components.
But if that's been working for
you, that's great, and you
probably stick with it.
In general, you can still factor
out smaller helper
methods containing interesting
sub-components of your
business logic and use them
across Android and Java.
But if you're extending
composite directly and using
UI fields, that component
definitely
isn't reusable on Android.
AUDIENCE: One more.
So how different is GWT UI
EventBinder from EventBus of
Guava library?
ERIK KUEFLER: So I'm definitely
taking some
inspiration from that there.
All EventBinder is doing is it's
really just a very thin
wrapper around the EventBus
that's built into GWT.
It's just a way to automate
the way in which you bind
those event handlers.
So it's not much different
from what's
already built into GWT.
That's a lot like what's
built into Guava.
Guava is a little
more powerful.
It has full reflection, which
is a big advantage.
It dispatches events in a
slightly different way, but if
you've used Guava's EventBus,
you'll probably feel pretty
comfortable using GWT's.
The other big difference is
that in GWT, all of your
events have to extend from this
event type, whereas on
Guava, you can just fire any
object on your EventBus.
That ends up not being too big
a deal, because it's not hard
to just create an event
wrapping the
type you want to fire.
So they're pretty similar.
AUDIENCE: Last one--
does Google use this concept
for Android apps in Wallet?
So my question is, do you
use MVP [? pattern ?]
for the Wallet application for
Android and also as a web
application?
Or is it something that's
developed separately?
ERIK KUEFLER: I think it
definitely varies a lot
between teams.
On my team, we have a completely
separate code base
for our Android versus
our web application.
And that's just because
the UIs for them
are different enough.
There's different enough things
that we're optimizing
for that there's not a huge
amount of code sharing we take
advantage of.
But I suspect there's
some other team to
do that a lot more.
It's not something I can really
speak to, though.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
something about Views and how
simple they are most of the
time in most applications.
I think the reality is that
most applications
have a mix of both.
So you've got some Views that
are very simple, like you
said, and some Views that
are more complex.
Then you need a lot of
abstractions between the
different Views.
I can see that it would help if
you use some sort of MVP or
some sort of abstraction
in your Views.
So what is the recommendation
for using a mix of the two
approaches?
Do you have any experience
using the mix?
Or is it possible, or what is
the complications there?
ERIK KUEFLER: I think these two
things mix really well.
So in the application I work
with, we started with a more
complex one, where we used
MVP for everything.
And when I realized it was
easier to do it this way, we
in piecemeal re-factored things
to use these simpler,
smaller Views.
It's really pretty transparent
to the application and what's
using what.
So if you're using a more
complex View, you have your
View, which is a widget,
extends, composite.
It has a Presenter behind it.
And then if you change that
one component to being a
built-in single component, it
doesn't really change from the
point of view of the rest of the
application, because it's
still just a widget that you
can include directly in
whatever its parents are.
Similarly, if you start simply
and need to break it out, the
fact that you're factoring out
a Presenter class is really
just an implementation detail
that shouldn't affect you in
the rest of the world.
Again, start with the simplest
implementation
you can think of.
And then it's never hard to just
extract another layer out
of that for testability later.
So I think that's something
that works really well.
AUDIENCE: And is there any
disadvantages with using the
first approach, the composite
pattern, like in terms of
maintainability of the EventBus
working with the
EventBus and cleaning up the
EventBus and stuff like that?
ERIK KUEFLER: In terms of
EventBus, I don't think this
pattern really has
much effect.
So if you've split these apart,
you have a Presenter
that's listening on the
EventBus, has these event
handlers fire on the bus.
When you combine them, you're
doing all the same things,
just from one single
class here.
So you're pretty much
using EventBus in
exactly the same way.
Either way, you inject it into
your logic class, you register
it, you fire events on it.
I don't think there's a
whole lot difference
doing it this way.
AUDIENCE: And one
last question--
what is the future of GWT?
ERIK KUEFLER: The
future of GWT?
AUDIENCE: GWT in general.
ERIK KUEFLER: There's a session
later today that's
laying out the roadmap for what
exactly is happening.
It's definitely something that's
still being supported.
Control was recently transferred
over to a steering
committee outside of Google.
So I think the GWT team is
expecting the open source
world to get a lot more
vibrant around it.
So it's something that's
definitely going, definitely
still healthy.
We're using it a ton
inside Google.
So I'm not on the GWT team.
I don't know the details.
So you should go to that
presentation later.
But it's not something
I'm worried about.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
Thanks.
ERIK KUEFLER: Thank you.
I think I'm out of time.
If you guys could please rate
this session as you're
leaving, either through your
Android apps, or just by
taking a picture those QR codes
over there, that would
be a huge help to me.
So thanks for coming by.
I'll be around to
answer questions
afterwards if anyone wants.
[APPLAUSE]